und für alle die sich in diesen zeiten
nach einem ja auch normalität sehen im
saarland wird am sonntag gewählt
ein bundesland ungefähr so groß wie das
saarland lädt zu einer good old
fashioned landtagswahl
ministerpräsident und titelverteidiger
tobias von der cdu muss dann wohl um
seinen job zittern in umfragen liegt er
nämlich teilweise deutlich hinter der
spd mit spitzenkandidatin anke rehlinger
möglicherweise auf die quittung für sein
wir reden uns doofes tankstellen video
oder es liegt daran dass er neulich ein
kompetenzteam vorgestellt hat obwohl er
seit jahren mit einem kabinett regiert
das im idealfall kompetent sein sollte
denkt man und dann kriegt der pechvogel
auch noch corona in der hochphase des
straßenwahlkampf was macht man da
und ich bin der digital auf ihn und
deswegen haben wir diesen hobby tobi
sozusagen aus gesamt und damit bin ich
jetzt sei nämlich in quarantäne bin
unterwegs tag wie nacht
super idee oder robbi tobbi
beziehungsweise robbi tobbi wegen der
kindersendung hobby tobbi und das
fliewatüüt wer kennt sie nicht aus dem
jahr
1972 so kriegt man die internet kids von
heute mit anspielungen auf 50 jahre alte
sendung wie denn sonst da muss man sagen
tobias hans hat sein amt ja nie bei
einer wahl gewonnen sondern damals von
aa kk geerbt und das erklärt natürlich
auch da kommt die rolle robbi tobbi
hallo hätten sie zeit und interesse sich
mal mit mir über das saarland zu
unterhalten die passt gerade irgendwie
gar nicht alles klar dann kommen ja sehr
gute idee macht das robbi tobbi
nervensäge aber wenn sie das schon
seltsam fand meine damen und herren dann
gucken sie mal was die gegenkandidatin
von der spd gemacht hat
ich bin anke rehlinger und weil ich
gerade in quarantäne bin nehme ich euch
einfach somit durch unser schönes
saarland kommt mit nähe danke ich darf
nicht mit fremden frauen mitgehen die
saarland wahl wir fassen zusammen ein
ipad tritt an gegen einen papp
aufsteller inhaltlich sind die beiden
übrigens kaum zu unterscheiden also was
die programme angeht während alle
parteien die nicht cdu oder spd heißen
am sonntag vor der fünf-prozent-hürde
zittern auch die kandidatin der grünen
und das trotz ihrer
grenzenlosen heimatliebe was ist im
saarland so schön am saarland ist so
schön dass alles so nah beieinander ist
und ich finde die natur im saarland
besonders schön ja darf das kurz
übersetzten das schönste am saarland ist
dass man so schnell wieder raus ist und
wissen sie wir am sonntag noch zittern
muss friedrich merz hier in klassischer
schröder kim gebets pose vor dem haus
die wahl im saarland ist nämlich seine
erste als cdu-chef und es ist ja muss
man sagen echt nicht leicht im moment
opposition zu sein in kriegszeiten an
der regierung nörglern ist mag der
wähler gar nicht zumal ist ja die cdu
unter merkel war die uns die ganze
abhängigkeit von putin maßgeblich mit
eingebrockt hat hier herr merz cdu
selbstkritik und wir stoppen mal mit wie
lange genau die union hat in den 16
jahren ihrer regierungsverantwortung
diese abhängigkeit mit vorangetrieben da
trifft sie doch jetzt noch eine
mitverantwortung
natürlich natürlich und das bestreitet
ja niemand von uns aber in den letzten
19 der letzten 23 jahre waren
sozialdemokraten in der regierung
das waren ja über drei sekunden bevor
andere schuld war aber wie gesagt
opposition ganz schwierig im moment in
diesem jahr kann man wenn es wenn es
ganz blöd läuft als union vier
landtagswahlen verpacken saarland
schleswig-holstein nrw und niedersachsen
mit einer union die ja natürlich noch
ihre neue rolle sucht wer glaubt dass
opposition mist ist der wird auch
irgendwann misst erleben wer da glaubt
dass es misst ist dann wird es auch am
schluss mit opposition ist für uns nicht
mist opposition ist für uns opportunity
opposition ist operativ opposition ist
opportunity und das sieht man
what it means man weiß es net ich sage
die union muss die opportunity nutzen
und wieder eigene themen setzen
natürlich carsten lindemann macht's vor
carsten linnemann der stellvertretende
cdu vorsitzende
der versuchte es zum beispiel mit der
wehrpflicht beziehungsweise der
forderung nach der allgemeinen
dienstpflicht großartig wir müssen
wieder 18-jährigen beibringen wie man
hände auf din a4 faltet nur so geht es
gut der generalinspekteur der bundeswehr
bourne ist zwar gegen die wehrpflicht
aber was weiß der schon
[Musik]
oh gott der dreh für die nk